so hello everyone
today we're going to talk about why we
were in a pickle a little while ago
so but first before we do that let's
give ourselves a little bit of an
introduction
go to the
oh yeah
so who are we well uh we're from enaco
uh we're both data scientists so my name
is uh courtney friends and as we just
discussed i've studied metrics here
but i've mainly been working on the tone
and the smart thermostat and that's
something that's very interesting but
we'll talk about that in a little while
let's first introduce himself i'm rick
i'm a data scientist um
i do a lot of data science but i also
like being involved with the data
engineering and as you might know with
data engineering comes
a lot of interesting challenges
um
and in a sense i like those challenges
as much as the actual data signs work
because i don't know if there is an
interesting problem i'm always in for it
trying to solve it so that's what we are
going to talk to you about today
so let me start with a story
the story starts
on a friday afternoon
we thought oh
we have our nice cloud environment where
we run our jobs
hey there's a new version and it has
like some performance improvements some
other nice improvements let's make a
small merge request i will just update
the version for uh the jobs what could
possibly go wrong
actually this this
it didn't really happen on friday
afternoon but just for dramatic purposes
of course
this happened we got a very large error
and we didn't know what was happening
and and it was also the beginning of a
long story
far as it was a very long story for you
it will be about half an hour
um
the only hint that we got at the
beginning was an integer is required god
type bites
and has to do something with pickling so
that's a little bit of a teaser but
we'll
tell you in the stock how the way we
store our machine learning models
suddenly became incompatible overnight
and how we kind of had to rethink
some of our steps and uh what we did in
the end it's also a little bit
open-ended but we also have some
insights that we want to share with you
first uh coney will talk a little bit
about
a bit of the broader context i will
guess yeah so before we dive into the
technical details uh let's talk about
the tone
so the tone is a smart thermostat from
eneko
and
it's
special in that sense that you connect
it to your smart meter a smart meter has
two types of
resolution data so it has high
resolution
that's unchanged or on second or one
second interval data
and the low resolution data if you've
been to the talk this morning from rick
and feno earlier
you've seen the talk about the low
rational resolution data and what we do
with that
but today we're going to mainly talk
about
the data services that we deliver with
the high-resolution data
so the phone is a smart thermostat but
it gives you a lot more a lot more
information
so one of the things is for example the
waste checker i'll tell you a little bit
more about that in a second
we have the bill breakdown that's the
desegregation of your energy bill into
different appliances
uh we have the weight check
so we try to
give you advice on whether your heating
is on w while you aren't home
we have monthly energy insights so we
gave you an energy booklet or a digital
booklet
that states something about
sustainability of your home and your
behavior
we have boiler monitoring so we try to
monitor your boiler and see whether your
your pressure for example is varying
over time or not
and we have simple soda monitoring so
it's your solar system up to par with
the rest
of what it should be um so that's what
the tone mainly does if we go to the
next slide i'll explain something about
the waste checker so as you rather
delete it
you've seen that we're going to talk
about machine learning at scale right so
before we talk about skill let's discuss
a little bit of the waste checker use
case
so with the waste checker use case we
try to identify um whether your
appliances and appliances that you use
whether they are used in a wasteful
manner or not
so for example is your dishwasher on the
too high temperature is your washing
machine
not on the eco mode
and we try to give you a hint on whether
um yeah you should use it differently or
not
but what's the skill in this
picture so if you go to the next one so
if we talk about skill we have around
two to two hundred thousand customers
that use the tone
and every day we detect around 75 000
dishwasher cycles and if you do the math
that's perfectly honor you see that
that's roughly 30 years 13 years of
dishwashers running
end to end so continuously and over a
quarter of them are not used efficiently
so if we can
defect those and say like hey come on
use it perhaps a little bit more
efficient so put on the eco mode or
watch it on a low temperature then we
can really move the needle forward on
helping people be more sustainable at
home
but that's that's just one use case
let's talk a little bit about our
general setup that we have at
our team
so this is the
a simple slide that shows our
architecture
so our iot stream should click click the
next one
rit stream is around one terabyte per
day that we get of smart media data so
that's quite a lot and
especially the iot stream and the click
data blocks those are separate from
all the other ones the other ones are
connected through a platform
or
[Music]
it's a platform but it's called
databricks and databricks is mainly
a supplier for apache spark at a
corporate
level
so our batch processing is in databricks
our notebooks are in databricks our
real-time services are in databricks and
so our dashboard and that's important
for later on why we're trying to move a
dbr version
higher
and we use ammo flow and mflow registry
and also in the talk this morning uh if
you if you were there we talked a little
bit about how we use mlflow and demo
flow registry there
but if we click on the next one
we have in the delta lake of around one
petabyte of data so that's that's quite
a lot so that's also why we have to use
spark
to make it all happen and then we'll
flow around 500 models unlocked and
those are uh also experiments but also
experiments that we use in production
and for the in our flow registry we have
around eight deployments that we
actively track so eight models that are
actively in
production
and besides the models that we track are
also a lot of unsupervised models um so
if you click next
we have around uh one million
unsupervised models that we train and
that's mainly made up out of the build
breakdown that i talked earlier about we
have several appliances there for each
user and each appliance
um we train in superfood unsupervised
model on the fly so that's how you get
to the one million number if you ever
want to know where that comes from
so
i think
the next one is for you
yes so
this is a picture that might look
familiar but i will go over it a little
bit
so basically our flow
exists of two things at the bottom
we have all the experimentation that we
do to make a model the top part is about
using a model right
so there's one flow
when you want to use a model every day
you want to have some batch pipeline
that for everybody
detects the appliances or judges that
efficiency or inefficiency or
anything of that matter
and at the bottom is your ammo flow
where you have like a notebook or any
environment that you want to train a
model but the important part and i guess
the focus of this talk to me today is in
the middle part so how
do you go from your model that you have
live that you want to preserve
to something that you finally use in
prediction
and a very common method to do this is
called pickling that's why there is also
a picture of pickles there and i think i
didn't look this up but i think the
reason is this
if you have basically pickling is also
this right you take some fresh
cucumber some fresh vegetable and then
you put it
in a pickle solution
[Music]
to preserve it so you can use it at a
later time so
pickles or algerica in dutch
are a way of preserving food but they're
also a way of preserving
uh models and as a matter of fact
there's also an english idiom which
means i'm in a pickle that means you're
in a bad situation and
well there's a little bit of truth in
all of those three explanations today
so basically what happens when you do
pickle
you just have your model you fit it
there's a very minimal machine learning
example
and then
in our case we use the ammo flow library
but it's just a wrapper that under the
whole hood calls from like maybe job lib
or cloud pico or the other pico library
there's some there's a number of
libraries that can do this conversion
from a python object can be any object
in our case a machine learning object
including the state of the
object and maybe some other functions
that you wrote can also be included in
the pixel and you just take whatever
object is in memory in your python
memory
and you just convert it to a bench of
zeros and ones um and in our in our
case we also lock a number of other
things so we have like a condo yamaha
yamo we have a requirements text to kind
of like specify what was their
environment when we were training so
what python version would you use what
library versions did we use but the
important part like the
the the
well the real pickle that's the
model.pickle that you see here
um so that's the bottom part right you
make a model and then you convert it to
binary and then later you can convert
that binary back to a python object and
that
is an object where you can call predict
or you can load it into spark and do
your predictions there
whatever you like
but
here comes the painful part
because you're basically just converting
everything that you have to binary data
in that specific python environment if
you're converting it back it must be
compatible to whatever you had otherwise
it's a little bit like you have your
roller coaster tycoon cd and you put it
in your new macbook and it says i cannot
read this i have a completely different
environment
so um
you need to have the same
versions and in our case
when we switched our environments from
some environment
on python 3.7 and we tried to load it
back on 3.8 we got this weird error says
i expected this type
error could have been better but it
basically meant
i cannot read what you wrote back then
anymore
so
that's a little bit to go back to our
flow because we use spark in a
distributed way
uh to make our predictions so basically
all we do here we have spark we have
some
scala we have some python code all in
spark
and we can use spark is a distributed
engine so you can have any number of
workers and they all read a little bit
of the data and then do the prediction
of there and it's really nice because it
can scale easily to
all the sizes that grenade just showed
on the other slide
but the thing is
because we have this pickle in the
middle
we kind of have a locked in dependency
between the python version of our spark
and the python version that we
originally trained there and that's some
that's kind of the hard realization we
came to that
uh
either
you kind of like need to stick
to the same python version everywhere
or
um okay i'll get to that in a second so
this is we run on a platform called
databricks basically everything we do we
do there and they manage
an environment for each which is called
dataworks runtime and it comes with a
bunch
of spark versions but also some machine
learning library versions and really
nice for us because we don't have to
worry
that much about keeping track of all the
versions and we have kind of like one
universe version um but the thing is
they release a lot of new updates
usually exciting updates with new
features maybe performance improvement
for spark
and that makes us want to upgrade but in
some some cases the upgrades can be
breaking as we just saw before
um
and this is just a bit of a timeline of
like when the release versions were
upgraded so
uh actually i think it was the beginning
of this year when we
first thought like okay let's see if we
can do this update and by the time we're
done we're thinking okay maybe like not
migrate to 8.4 but let's go to the next
version already because there's also a
long-term support version now
so
basically our problem was we have kind
of this login this locked in
issue with
the model that we have trained which is
pickled and we want to load it but it is
needs to be the same version so in a
really basic way what can we do about it
well
either we need to move away from using
this pickle and find some other way to
preserve our models or vegetables or
whatever
or we need to find some way to keep
using
the old
version that the model was trained on
just so our prediction job will just be
in like a separate container and it will
always have that same old version that
we once started with
or we need
to just do it again and make a new
pickle and basically those are the three
a little bit fundamental
ways we saw about this problem and coney
will go more in-depth about what it
means and how how you could implement
some of those
yeah so
as rick just explained there were three
fundamental ways how we saw it that we
could solve the problem and
one was the portable format one was a
containerization option and the other
one was very locally retraining also for
the environment not just for the data
and the portable format is onyx i've
heard someone already talked about it
but
onyx is a portable format in a sense
that you can
define a model in a more generic format
than what you've had and you can take it
to another hardware platform for example
you can take the raspberry pi you could
take it to your smartphone you could do
inference from there and also it can be
quite agnostic to
software versions that are in there so
that's quite useful you can just
define it in that format and then just
take it from a to b to c to d to e if
you want to
containerization we mainly looked at mlf
projects
and why it's because we're already on
the databricks stack so if we're going
to think about a containerization
solution
um it has to work similarly with our
other data ecosystem because that's
easier to integrate otherwise it would
be quite hard
and then the retraining that's something
that i will talk about a little bit
later but if you move to the next one
yes and as a side note this is just
things we we consider as options but
maybe there's like pummel there's other
portable formats you can use docker
airflow
it's just examples of the kind of
solutions but not a specific preference
for those
so yeah let's go to the portable format
that we discussed onyx
well there are a few benefits and a few
drawbacks to why you would go for such a
solution so one thing that's a that's a
benefit and a drawback at the same time
is that in our use case we have a lot of
uh pipelines or psychic turn pipelines
but we've defined them with custom
transformations and those custom
transformations are really um
necessary for all the signal processing
that we do
so you have to disentangle the model
from the pipeline and that's something
that
it requires a lot of work for us to to
make it happen but at the same time it
can be a benefit because you have your
model separately defined somewhere else
your pipeline
you just got it in spark for us for
example
it's environment agnostic something that
i just mentioned
and for some models it has faster
influence than when you just try to load
the pickle load the native libraries and
just do influence there
it has support for a wide variety of
models and it hasn't so it has support
for light gbm it has support for
byte or stanford because it originated
from
format for neural networks
and it's also backed by energy giant so
it's backed by microsoft and by the
linux
linux foundation
but in our case we have to revamp a lot
of the models that are there um
although there's a wide variety of
models that are supported
it is quite limited so for example if we
have some esoteric model that we want to
add into onyx that would be quite
difficult to do
and it's dependent on development of
onyx runtime because you define the form
of
in onyx and then you have to run it
somewhere and you use onyx runtime for
that
and moreover one of the reasons why
separating the pipeline and the model is
quite difficult is that
if you
want to integrate a pipeline into onix
you have to define all the custom
transformations in the mathematical
syntax of onix so that's in our case
quite difficult to do um but it would be
something that that we could do i'm not
going to spoil the solution or the the
thing that we chose until the end of
course
so if you go to the next one
so containerization um well i think
a lot of people know what
containerization is but let's go to the
benefits of the drawbacks
it has benefits in the sense that
the models and environments are stable
so you can just have your container you
can load your model in there
and you can define all the
dependencies that you have there just
keep them at the same version throughout
um
the benefit of project is it's um tied
into the database ecosystem so you can
just incorporate it and what flow and
our flow is mainly the amount registry
that we use for
registering our models
seeing which one on production which one
are staging
it's agnostic to the dbr version so you
can just containerize it and you can
change the dvr version in the rest of
your stack to whatever version you'd
like to
but
in our case
if you don't keep it up to date if you
don't keep the dependencies in the
container up to date it will likely be
outdated over time and that's something
that
you have to be willing to accept if you
want that
or
or you have to update it each time and
then there's not really a difference
between this one and the last option
and in our case it's useful that we
could incorporate external jars or eggs
and that's something that's not possible
in mflow projects at this moment
it also would require adjustment of the
pipeline and the model
so as i explained in the earlier
version with onyx
we would have to do a good revamp of the
models that we have
and we have to change how we do
influence right now because you have to
uh surf the influence from the container
and that's something that's not done in
our pipelines right now so we really
have to revamp that so in our scenario
this would also entail quite some manual
work
so perhaps this one isn't the right
option but we'll see
so the last one periodically retraining
so if you go to the next one
so periodically retraining so we train
we retrain every now and then for the
new data that comes in so that's
obviously something that's very useful
but something that we also considered
why if we retrain why don't we just
retrain on the latest environment there
are some good reasons why you shouldn't
or why you perhaps wouldn't because
if there are any changes or breaking
changes in the dependencies that you
have then your model will also break
but in our case
how we've set up
working within the
team that we have
it's easier to embed it in our current
process so that we just for example
periodically retrain it each
a quarter or each half year and then if
anything comes up fix it at that moment
because that's easier manageable
than doing that
big leaps every half year or
every year in that sense
in our case if we just pipelinify it as
we already have all the other pipelines
it can be more extensively monitored and
also
it can be embedded in the rest of our
crcd so that's also something that's
quite neat
but it has some drawbacks you have to do
retraining perhaps more often than you
would
you would like to so you have to
consider the factor of compute
or the cost of compute
and even if you add more models to your
model stack um if you train them more
often than you would like to
then
of course the same argument holds the
cost of computation will still be higher
um
and if you embed it in a maintenance
fashion so as we would like to so just
pipelinify it then also the maintenance
work that we have
will be a little bit uh
more than usual but
that's something that i think for us was
a good solution
let's go to the next one
today so huhan who won well in the end
i think during the
solutions that i discussed it was a
little bit obvious that this one was
going to win in the end
um although
this is pretty specific within our
constraints so for us this is a really
good use case to do this but for other
people the portable format could be a
really good solution or containerization
could be really really well
or something that works really well
but for us
given the size of our team given how
we've already structured
our current efforts so how we
pipelinified almost everything
this is something that
uh we've considered to be the best
option forward because we can keep it
all up to date
we can make use of the latest features
and we can also retrain it
for the data and for the environment
at a very periodic manner
so what are our main takeaways besides
the choice
um
well pickling models if you do that it
locks you into your
python and library version and that's
something that
yeah should you be willing to do that
we're not so sure that we want that
portal forms are very useful
but it's hard to implement in our case
because we had so many custom
transformations
can be useful but as i mentioned it's
hard to separate it out for us but if
you have a separated uh setup and if
you're going to
start off this is perhaps a good option
for you if you want to
and retraining as i said it makes it
easier for us to keep our models up to
date and also
to keep our data and models up to date
so this was
this were our key takeaways and this was
our struggle with
picking
[Applause]
thanks
any questions
where's the where's the cube the box
do you want to throw
hey um nice presentation um just a quick
question um so right now it sounds like
you're retraining the model whenever
you're upgrading python versions or
other library versions
do you ever have a need to
reuse old models at some future point in
time for example to do like a comparison
between how the old model was performing
and how the new model is performing and
how are you um how are you doing that
yeah so that's uh something that we that
we have to do
um so every time we train a new version
uh or a new iteration of the model we
really look at how does it compare to
the other models that we have and the
main thing that we use threats and flow
so i'm a flow and everflow registry is
where we
really keep track of our all
experiments and also if we do any
retraining how well does it compare to
the other models that we have
so if you retrain better make sure that
your model is better than the previous
one or at least up to par with the last
one so
good question but that's that's that's
something that we do yeah cool thank you
i have a bit of different questions so
um use databricks notebook so you are
actually developing ides
sorry and do you use databricks
notebooks in production yeah
why do you choose for using the
notebooks in production instead of
i i can elaborate a little bit on this
as well so
um
what we use the notebooks for is mainly
for experimentation and the nice thing
is that they are on the platform we so
we can also directly access the data you
don't have to export any data
[Music]
for
usually we try to keep it as much to
only the model itself as possible so any
of the other spark jobs that we write
around at or some of the transformations
that we do for example i know resampling
electricity data or something that we
try to write
in separate code in our code base so we
have
most of the code we develop is like in
our code base and then we can write unit
test integration tests whatever we like
both for scala called and python called
then we put that in a jar and egg which
you also saw happening during the
presentation but
the machine learning for us it's easier
to do in a notebook because it just it
just feels more natural to be closer to
the data and to have some interaction as
well
we're not at this stage yet
for some of the models we tried also
putting some of the feature engineering
into unit tested jobs but i've
i find it it's a bit of a
uh
there's a bit of a tension there i feel
yeah because if you put something
in a nice job and you read all the unit
tests and integration tests then if you
want to add a feature afterwards it's
going to be a lot more work so
unfortunately we have some fortunately
we have some good bookkeeping to still
keep track of the models and their
performance
um but i think
i think normally in in like software
engineering you can do test driven
development right you say i want this
and this and this outcome and then i
write my software and i feel data
science is the other way around where
you just go from the data you experiment
and then you kind of learn what you want
so i think there's an interesting
tension between how to do good software
engineering and good data science at the
same time yeah i think it is a
hard thing especially if you use
databricks we have the same problem we
are trying to find a way actually not to
use notebooks
and it is challenging it is not easy
the main reason with how to incorporate
it in cicd pipelines is model retraining
you just
and trigger notebooks or what they do
so the
trigger notebooks
so
currently the models are not
in the cicd pipeline yet and that's also
one of our point points so we definitely
also experience pay points yeah so for
that it's easier to use python scripts
then you would have to translate your
notebooks into python scripts
um and use database job apis i guess
that's what yes
we can chat a little bit later yeah that
would be nice it would be interesting to
exchange some thought
oh it's microsoft
okay
meanwhile um so we you touched very
briefly on the topic of retraining a
model and when should you do that and i
could definitely agree like you don't
want to do it every hour because that's
a whole lot of compute but at the same
time you know gas prices suddenly rise
up so there's something to be said that
on the short term there might be
something happening that's causing a lot
of different behavior
so
that makes me wonder especially in your
market i could imagine that you might
want to be able to trigger off
retrainings manually but i can also
imagine that you might want to schedule
this on a regular basis do you have any
insights on on that because it seems
like a relevant topic no
yeah i i it's an interesting question
it's also something we've been thinking
about because i've
it really depends on the use case as
well i think so for some of the use
cases we
also about
the amount of training data that you
have available right if you only have a
fixed training set
there's not that much use i think in
running it again every night right but
especially for example the solar model i
was also talking about this morning i
think there if you have continuous data
available then it also makes sense to
continuously
retrain um
i don't know we have a lot of
future visions about this also i think
it would be nice to if you do the
inference to also infer on like a sample
data set and then you can maybe track if
there's any drift
and use it in that way
but
we don't have that yet
so
yes in the back
because if you're going to upgrade a low
level thing like a python library or a
python version number all the models
break all at once and then
because your production environment has
a very specific version how do you make
sure that they don't overload a group of
people with a lot of work to fix these
models
so
your question is
how do we manage all those dependencies
everywhere if something changes or okay
so if you had one production environment
with one particular version of python
yes you upgraded that version
yes all the models that would break with
the new version broke all at once
because
you would run them all that's day
how do you manage the workload on the
people who have to fix these models
because now they have a lot of miles to
fix all at once
well yeah
so first of all of course first we have
an acceptance environment so we can spot
it in advance then roll back and
just take it easy before all panics
breaks loose
um
but indeed that's kind of that's kind of
the pain that we've been having right so
it was also a good lesson in going back
over some of the models to see hey i
made something and even though i have
all the nice versioning tools how really
is it e
how easy is it really to reconstruct
a training data set and how can i
structure that
in a better way so i think
it's not easy but it was a lesson for us
like in how can we set it up in a better
way so it's also more reproducible and
less man-hours to
redo some things yeah and also think if
they all break at the same time
it's quite likely that's the same
cause and then it's just a matter of
trying to find what's the actual problem
that caused it and then you only have to
fix it once instead of for every model
so it's quite dependent on what breaks
and what what
um what causes it to break if it's like
different causes for each model it's
going to be a huge workload but if it's
only one cast for all models
then it's better management
so if i can ask the last question which
is related so if you would have had many
different models from different teams
would you choose the containerized
option then
that's a good one
okay maybe it's something for the break
because we have five minutes to switch
for anybody who wants so
let's give a big applause
you